- I think the one thing I would
add just I'll jump into this one
'cause I love it so much.
I think the one thing that true
entrepreneurs need to realize is
that the market doesn't care.
Let me tell you one
great thing about the market.
It wants to make money.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
Are you filming this meeting?
No, right?
I'll go selfie
right now instead.
Alright, Babin,
get out of my face.
Stop falling me.
Heading to a meeting.
No Babin, he's out.
Gloomy as shit in New York City.
That's how it is.
What's on my mind?
Nothing really.
Good fantasy baseball day.
Homer from Correa and Springer.
My super Astros.
I got Beltran too.
I'm all about
the Astros this year.
Shit, where am I going?
And just rock and rolling.
Bunch of fucking
senior meetings today.
Client stuff, internal stuff.
Jessica Alba's stopping
by today which is amazing.
I'm gonna interview her
in front of the company.
Little fireside chat.
And then I'm going to the
Knicks game with Jim Kilts,
former CEO of
Gillette, Nabisco and Kraft.
Absolute legend
in the CPG world.
So it should be a good day.
("Can You Swim"
by Lilo Key)
Okay. Yeah, I think it's fine.
Hi.
Really what I want to focus
on more than anything here is
culture hacking and
process of how we execute that.
- [Woman] Now I always
notice faces as logos especially
associated with food.
Which I think is
such a creepy American...
- Well good news, if that
creeps you out the whole
country will creep you out.
That's all we do.
- [Woman] Right.
- Everything is
based on that same thesis.
- [Woman] That's us.
- Yeah.
You're literally wearing
your choker because of that.
- [Woman] Yeah. For sure.
- You just don't
fully realize why,
and the people that interact
with that don't fully realize
why but that's
the whole punchline.
- [Woman] Right, it's like we're
products of our surrounding.
- We're also
PR'ing ourselves 24/7/365.
- [Woman] Right.
- Now manifested in a way
that's so extreme with selfies.
- Right.
- [Gary] And it's
why I love live events.
Everything is about proving
you're somewhere or
expressing yourself.
Literally Andy picked
that sweatshirt for a reason.
It says something about himself.
- You're right.
- [Gary] He says, look, I'm
cool 'cause I know this brand.
I mean it's interesting.
- Yeah.
("Inside Of Me"
by Justin Stone)
- I have insurance, right?
You're just watching.
- [Man] We're watching and in
reality we know the reason our
product works is because of how
incredibly busy
local business owners are.
- I get it, that's what I mean.
The reason insurance works is
you don't get hit by
lightning that often.
- [Man] Yeah, exactly.
They get super excited
about being able to ask--
- Ty! You like that one, right
That was a good one, right?
That was right.
(group laughter)
No, I think
that's right by the way.
- [Man] Yeah.
- I think that's right.
There was this part
and then I did it. Right?
And this one I made millions,
this one I made
tens of millions,
this one I made billions, right?
There's a true narrative there.
It's very close.
Is Frank here?
Bang. That's huge.
- [Rachel] How are you?
- [Gary] Amazing.
- [Rachel] I was
just telling DRock,
we talked about this
when I was here but like,
the wedding filmmakers could
not believe I was on DailyVee.
You're a celebrity
to a lot of people
but the wedding filmmaking.
You're doing the
rising tide thing.
Like this group of people
might be your most dedicated,
I think, fan base.
- Everybody's gonna
be the most dedicated.
- We're using money,
it's going okay.
People are like weird about
weddings and people either get
media or they don't.
- [Gary] Those are just excuses.
People want to write
checks or they don't.
- [Rachel] 100%.
- They believe in--
- [Rachel] This was
the feedback I'm getting.
- It's fake.
It's what they give to every,
you either believe in the
founder and the thesis.-
[Rachel] Yeah.
- Nobody's so confused.
- [Rachel] No,
they're not confused.
- Do you know what I mean?
- [Rachel] I think people...
- They're all excuses bet on the
fact that they're not sure if
you or it is right,
which is fine.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- Is the jockey right?
Is the horse right?
- [Rachel] Yes.
- Whatever, but
don't over (gags).
- [Rachel] No, I'm so--
- Right?
Feedback, yeah.
And it's not, I don't
think you're dwelling.
I just think you
need to really know that
they're just
basically all excuses.
If you can just
build a business,--
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- for the next two
years and do nothing else.
Not worry about how much
you're leaving on the table.
Not thinking about
accelerated growth.
Thinking about
building a foundation.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- I think you'll win.
Great new potential
business meeting.
("Right Now" by Bazanji)
just running a business.
Getting ready for some,
Jessica Alba coming in today.
As I mentioned
earlier in the phone video
so you didn't
need to repeat that.
Just good stuff, good meetings.
Meeting, meeting,
meeting, meeting, meeting.
Let's see.
Another potential client
in Europe coming through.
Oh, we have to go there, huh?
Okay.
Just all good stuff, man.
Being an executive.
You know, listen, I read
your guys comments.
I know I interrupt
people sometimes,
I'm sorry.
I already know what they're
going to say and so speed
matters and it can be rude
at times so I'm trying to be
better, thank you.
But mostly
I wish I could show you
everything but I can't.
We're trying.
This is why we're doing updates.
You know, this is
not "The Bachelor,"
this is not "Survivor."
This is like I'm
running a business.
Tyler just happens to be around.
So this is the documentation
of an entrepreneur building a
business empire.
("Can You Swim" by Lilo Key)
I love it.
I actually weirdly
prefer people think bad.
The best part is the
results are the results.
- [Man 2] Yeah, right.
Speaks for itself.
- If you care that you're down
14-0 in the first quarter you're
not coming back anyway.
- [Man 2] Right. Sure.
("Can You Swim"
by Lilo Key)
- You're not
even in the game, yet.
There's a long road--
- Yeah.
I need to give
you the full story.
- It's real good, right?
- Real good.
- I know. I know it's real good.
I know it is in my bones
'cause I know that there's,
I can feel it in the air.
Worked.
- Worked.
Exactly like the full--
- Do they really know?
Like are they freaking?
- Yeah, yeah.
Like Friday will be a
real good day. (laughs)
- Yeah!
Go figure this shit works.
- Right.
- Okay.
Yes, I want to do that.
Makes me so...
- [Gary] Hi, how are you?
- [Jessica] Is this your office?
- This is my office.
- [Jessica] (laughs)
It's amazing.
- [Gary] Guys, say
hello to my friend Jess.
(audience applause)
When did you start
thinking about or realize
that you had business interests?
- Hmmm.
I think I always
approached my career,
even when I was 12
and I started acting,
I was like what's the long game?
How do I stay relevant and
how do I become a real player?
And how am I going
to be meaningful?
And so, I was always pretty
strategic in the way that
I approached my career.
And I thought of myself as a
brand before it was a thing to
think of yourself as a brand.
I was always really cognizant
that anything that I associated
myself with was
going to be reflective of
how people thought of me.
- Yep.
- And I protected
that for a long time.
And when I decided
to launch my own brand,
I really feel like all of that
thought really got channeled in
the best way.
I didn't know what the outcome
would be but I was certainly
very aware of being protective
of my image from day one.
- I think the one
thing I would add,
just I'll jump in to this
one 'cause I love it so much.
I think the one thing that true
entrepreneurs need to realize is
that the market doesn't care.
Let me tell you one
great thing about the market.
It wants to make money.
Do I think some VCs may
say you don't look the part, no.
Sure but I got a news alert,
I don't usually invest in white
affluent dudes from good
families 'cause I don't think
they have a chip
on their shoulder.
So, I'm playing the reverse.
And the truth is I've been
wrong and I've been right.
So I think if you're a purebred
entrepreneur you realize you're
getting punched in the
fuckin' mouth 24/7/365 anyway.
The market is market and if you
dwell on what you are and
why you're not
winning because of that,
you would've never had a, it's
not different then the people we
said no to.
- You can't, I'm sorry.
- Please.
- You can't be a
victim of circumstance.
It's sort of like
blaming your parents.
It's like, yeah, right.
Everyone has a history and you
can blame your parents until
you're blue in the face
but if you only work on,
focus on that you've never
get over it and be an adult and
figure your own life out.
I think if I would've started
The Honest Company when I wanted
to start, it would've
been too early.
And actually having
three years of rejection
it gave me the
armor to take on
actually getting
funding and starting a
company and taking all
of the punches in my face,
in my eyes, in my ear,
in my nose that
constantly keep happening.
- And still do. Everyday.
- And still do
everyday, of course.
But I have more callouses
and so I can
take it differently.
- Jess, thank you so
much for stopping by.
- Yeah, thank you.
- I love you.
(audience applause)
Thanks guys.
Have a great night.
- Thank you everyone.
- You're so awesome.
Give me a hug.
Thank you so, so much.
- Yeah.
- You were great.
You enjoyed it?
- [Woman 3] Enjoy the game.
- [Gary] We will. (laughs)
How's everybody?
You guys enjoyed it?
- [Woman 4] Yeah.
- [Gary] Good.
He's learning?
Had a great meeting with a
incredible piece of software and